the Joe Rogan experience and there's
also probably some concern about other
countries getting ahead of us so you
have to do what you have to do if your
if your job is to protect the American
people and to keep the military strong
you just have to operate with that
premise that there's a bunch of other
people out there that are doing the same
thing for their country and trying to
take down the United States and we got
to stay ahead of the curve and make
human eating robots that can shoot
missiles absolutely I mean when I was
reporting the Pentagon's brain which is
about DARPA and I was sitting there with
scientists who are working on limb
regeneration right oh yeah what do they
do oh my god they have these little
salamanders I mean they're showing that
salamanders can regenerate their limbs
and so human their idea they're down at
UC Irvine they have this incredible lab
and they're funded by DARPA because
that's where the money it comes from
right and their idea is that humans
should be able to regenerate their limbs
and you know 50 years out we'll be doing
that and they're working on the science
for that well that's the same science
that allows for cloning and so in our
discussions because that's how I try to
report is like really ask people what
they think about future consequences and
they said to me your exact question
which is well Annie what if one day we
wake up and we find out that China has
cloned the first human or a dark horse
like Saudi Arabia you know the American
people are gonna freak out and go where
the hell was DARPA why aren't we ahead
of the curve so it's that there's a
chicken and the egg problem with that of
like well we have to stay ahead where
we're on top we want to be on top it's
kind of terrifying
I mean everything I write about is
terrifying well you have to take ambien
I'm more worried about no god no I'm I'm
more worried about coming on your show
and being asked tough questions and I am
about no it's using you but then I am
about I mean this stuff is informative
you know it's informative and it's a
longer conversation that's why I think
what you do with your podcast is awesome
because people can really get into the
thinking about
things right they can really and they
can move away from their own
preconceptions their own biases they're
bringing into it and they're stopping
for a minute and they're going what do I
really think about that and to really
think about something you need
information yeah an information can be
boring unless it's interestingly
presented through conversation through
you know uncomfortable conversation well
also uncompromised conversation where
you don't have a certain time period
that you have to smush something into
like a four minute segment on CNN or
something I mean that's impossible
what's so difficult I see people have
these conversations about books or
something that are trying to accomplish
very nuanced subject that they're trying
to discuss and you know there's another
person other sides like that's not true
and they're shouting over each other and
like boy just the pressure the people
have to understand that people do
understand but you have to reiterate it
and it has to be kind of drilled in your
head you're when you're pressuring
someone and and you're yelling back and
forth you're not even going to get a
good version of whatever this person's
argument is like you should have the
best version I want like if I'm gonna
have a disagreement with someone I want
the best version of their their point
and I want them to get it out with no
pressure I want to help them get it out
I'd like to reiterate it with them I
like to give them plenty of time I want
to know how you think I know what you're
thinking about I would love to talk to
these guys
I would love to loved it but the thing
is like you they can't tell you a lot of
this there's a Ramin for national
security reasons there's a lot of
reasons I sure if they want to keep
their job and stay alive they have to
they have to shut the [ __ ] up they can't
just talk about what they do and how
they do it and how and decisions that
maybe they made that were uncomfortable
they killed somebody that didn't think
maybe needed to die yeah but but that's
the reporters job or at least my job so
in other words okay so I go to visit
Billy wad is home and I knew I heard
stories about he's this legendary
operator right and he's also what's
called a singleton so he works alone and
when I was at the crawler mostly a
singleton right which is like he's got
one guy giving him orders
oh right he's out there oh my god I mean
Billy wall is right I mean back can we
back up first I'm gonna give you the
story of him okay so here's this guy
he's in he's in Vietnam and he's part of
what was called Mac V SOG right and
they're doing cross border missions into
Laos and it's so dangerous it's like
it's a CIA program that SOG stands for
studies and observations group I mean
it's supposed to sound like a bunch of
guys in Ivy League tower with bow ties
right but the guys on the ground called
it suicide on the ground that's how
dangerous it is a hundred percent of the
people had casualties right Billy hua
has nine Purple Hearts from the work he
did nine okay I mean they get shot they
bandaged themselves up they're you know
they're up in an aircraft because
they're limping instead of on the ground
you know viewing the missions the
warrants everybody's furious with the
government with the military there's no
room for special operators I mean
everything it's called the Time of
Troubles by them Billy was working in
the post office and he gets this knock
you know and it's like he's back in the
CIA now in 1977 so he was out free he
was out it was over Veon I mean he was
he was you know it was over that was it
he was working in the post office right
I mean a team needs you I mean but he
said the most incredible thing to me
because he said I and he doesn't ever
talk about fear and he said there was
only one time my whole life I've ever
been afraid and that was in the post
office whoa because he was getting back
into it probably had like recycled his
mind and put himself in a place I'm just
a civilian now and he said I'm gonna
wind up being one of those old guys
drinking beer at the end of the bar
talking about the war mmm right and
instead he gets called up by the CIA and
they send him to Libya in 1977 and his
cover is that he's training Qaddafi's
paramilitary guys in paramilitary
tactics I mean that's the beginning of
his career and it goes on all the way
until we were in Cuba I think was
actually some kind of a mission because
it was like what are we doing here in
Cuba doing infiltration and exfiltration
techniques allegedly with je Guevara son
but in any event you know when I went to
visit Billy well the first time he's got
this you know he's got certificates and
awards and medals all over the walls of
his home but there's one framed item
that I'm looking at and it's a knife and
there was a seal from the CIA and it
says in appreciation to the assassin mmm
and I said Billy tell me about that and
he said you know I can't talk about that
so I you know stayed with him for two
years now I mean stayed we conversed we
traveled I interviewed him you know
hundreds of hours and I kept asking him
about that award and he kept saying you
know I can't talk about that but as I
write in the book he couldn't talk about
it but others did so that's how a
reporter works you get introduced to
enough of his friends enough of the
others who are involved you make sure
they're a legitimate source and you
begin to find out what he can't talk
about and that's what I report in the
book and that is very explosive because
President Bush right after 9/11 created
what was called a stalker team and
ironically you know people have this
idea that we've been you know sending a
team of assassins around the world in
NATO partner countries and that what I
learned had never happened until right
after 11:00 with his stalker team 12 men
and actually one or two women the femme
fatale and they would go after bad guys
and they adopted the term from the
Reagan era so it was called pre-emptive
neutralization who was who are the women
there's always one woman on the team
that's what I was told by the guy who is
in charge of the stalker team and Mars
are well I mean he he gave me this great
example I don't report in the book what
I'll tell you right he said
so women have a different presentation
and this like he told me a story of a
woman sitting on a bench you know in
embracing a man right and no one thought
anything of it and it allowed her to spy
on someone in a manner that would a man
would it would have drawn attention and
then the stalker team could go so what
their job would be to is to conduct
surveillance of a target and they call
it making book they have to make book on
that individual so they know exactly
where the guy is and they're waiting on
the president's orders whether or not
they should take action and you know
that's where the that's where the
information stops right I say well then
what happens well that's all we can say
honey that must be so exciting like to
live like that
like all cloak-and-dagger gotta be so
exciting like it's I would take that
over a cubicle every day of the week I
really would well you might get killed I
might die in that damn cubicle too
I think it's why so many of these
operators stay in it long term right did
you ever see the television show the
Showtime show what the hell's are called
with the [ __ ] that show called that
the homeland yes yes well that's like
the whole premise like she's completely
addicted to being in that world
adrenaline I mean that's what that is
imagine jumping out of an aircraft
landing in you know behind enemy lines
and then your work begins and then you
have to get out that's why surprise kill
vanish I mean you got to surprise your
way in kill them and then get out and if
you're getting into they frame your
knife and give you a plaque Jamie I'm
gonna get you a knife it's an
appreciation of the assassins you're a
killer
it's just such a crazy way to live your
life but you know I'll take that over a
boring life I would take that over a
boring like every day of the week
[Applause]